on est bien peu de choses et mon ami la
rose me l'a dit ce matin
à l'orange je suis née
je me suis épanouie
bonjour et bienvenue dans notre nouvelle
épisode du petit Emir
la semaine dernière nous avons découvert
Adeline chez elle avec toute sa famille
cette semaine nous repartons à la
ressource pour voir où en sont les
répétitions et pour assister à un petit
moment de cohésion de groupe sur le
thème du sport
bonjour on est réunis au centre de la
ressource en ce mercredi toujours pour
la préparation du petit Emir là
aujourd'hui comme les dernières semaines
ont été très riches en émotions et en
travail on a décidé de se détendre
autour d'un petit match de basket pour
resserrer les liens et espérer vraiment
resserrer la dynamique de groupe donc
vous allez voir ces quelques images là
alors que l'ambiance bat son plein les
animateurs décident d'entrer sur le
terrain à leur tour pour une
confrontation toute amicale
après cette séance de partage et de
bonne humeur tout le monde se retrouve
en salle de répétition pour aller voir
Mathias Adeline Elisa en plein travail
ça c'est le premier jour articule prend
le temps de dire les mots
je t'achète
suite à ce moment fort et intense Marie
qu'a prend la parole pour un petit
débriefing
les comédiens et les musiciens sont
allés jouer au basket et nous pendant ce
temps avec Mathias Adeline et Lisa on a
commencé donc le début de la pièce et on
a essayé de placer en mise en scène déjà
les personnages les gestes
les internationaux etc donc voilà
c'était vraiment posé le début du
spectacle est arrivé à une qualité au
niveau du jeu qui commence vraiment à se
à se sentir donc je suis très contente
de cette ce début de répétition
c'est le moment que choisit Daniel pour
nous annoncer la fin de son stage et
donc son départ provisoire de l'aventure
elle en profite pour dresser un petit
bilan et nous présenter son successeur
encore une super journée passée sous le
signe du sport du rire de la
convivialité en ce qui me concerne
malheureusement l'aventure se termine
pour moi ici puisque je finis mon stage
à la ressource dans quelques jours et je
passe le relais à mon collègue Alexis
ici présent qui va me remplacer au cours
des répétitions à venir en tout cas moi
le projet du petit ami à me tient
vraiment à cœur donc je saurai me rendre
disponible pour venir à nouveau et
prendre part à cette aventure auprès des
jeunes c'est super aventure aujourd'hui
ça a été super avec les jeunes le sport
le théâtre puis depuis à sens venir je
crois que ça progresse beaucoup donc ça
promet donc j'ai m'investir pour faire
en sorte que ça marche aussi bien que
quand tu étais là
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine pour
découvrir la salle snowzolène et le
principe de stimulation sensorielle
ainsi que la suite des répétitions à
très bientôt